on a pu voir un principe unificateur
c'est la préservation de la vie humaine
qui a pris le pas sur toutes les autres
activités et notamment l'activité
économique
ça c'est une prise de conscience
absolument remarquable mais ce qui dans
le chapitre où vous montre le modèle que
j'appelle l'entrepôt génétique
on a vu une vision presque biologiques
or on s'aperçoit que la bonne santé
c'est aussi le contact social la
stabilité des relations humaines etc et
donc la santé est devenue au premier
point blanc mais ce qui a été un peu
abusif c'est presque une conception
biologiste de la alors que s'ils
voulaient la bonne santé s'était aussi
par ailleurs maintenir dans les ehpad
l'accès des familles à leurs anciens et
donc on s'aperçoit que en des partis sur
une vision assez biologique elle
s'aperçoit que il s'est en fait
l'ensemble des relations sociales qui
ceux qui sont affectés mais avec la
bonne prise de conscience un et moi
c'est que c'est le thème central de mon
livre dans des sociétés riches il n'y a
rien de mieux que de vivre longtemps en
bonne santé dans une société pleine de
dynamisme et de culture c'est ça qu'on a
retrouvée c'est à dire que on a retrouvé
ses valeurs de ses valeurs de base ce
qui pourrait justifier pour certains le
monde après celles dans le monde
hédoniste dans lequel l'économie et la
servante de l'épanouissement des talents
humains mais vous voyez très bien que la
la lutte au max pour les vaccins et
cetera réintroduit une vision très
biologique très fonctionnaliste alors
que c'est beaucoup plus important c'est
à dire que être garantir les conditions
de stabilité sociale et de confiance qui
permettent la vie la vie collective soul
et c'est ça que la crise aussi nous a
c'est dans le tout dernier chapitre de
l'ouvragé
je montre la question de la confiance et
des temps sociaux c'est faux
clairement reconstruire cette stabilité
qui expliquait la possible de développer
des talents personnels dans une société
au demeurant très individualiste
[Musique]